Bei Temperaturen von minus zehn
bis minus 20 Grad Celsius
laufen ihre Huskys zu Höchstformen auf.
Und auch Silvia Furtwängler ist in
ihrem Element.
Die Deutsche zählt zu den besten
Schlittenhundeführern der Welt.
Jeden Tag wird trainiert für bevorstehende
Rennen – in einer traumhaften Natur.
Es läuft. Es ist schön. Es ist still.
Es ist nicht laut, die Hunde hecheln.
Der Wind, der immer da ist,
und wenn er nicht da ist,
dann macht man sich Gedanken.
Es ist … ja, es ist einfach nur schön,
ich genieße es.
Es ist ihr Traum, sagt die 56-Jährige,
den sie hier leben kann.
Vor neun Jahren auf einer Expedition
entdeckte sie den einsamen Landstrich
für sich,
ließ Deutschland hinter sich
und wanderte mit ihrem Mann und ihrem
jüngsten Sohn in die norwegische Provinz aus
– 37 norwegische Huskys im Schlepptau.
Hunde sind, glaube ich, so ein Stück
weit wie ich.
Also, die Rasse sowieso auch. Also,
sind …
sind Einzelgänger, aber auch teamfähig,
sind Familienmenschen, aber doch auch
machen ihr eigenes Ding auch,
und …
ja, die haben einen …
sie sind ’ne Frohnatur!
Also, wenn man’s … wenn man’s sich
mit den Hunden nicht verscherzt,
dann hat man auch einen Partner fürs
Leben, ich find das toll.
Das Haus der Furtwänglers liegt
abgeschieden direkt an einem See.
Im Sommer nur mit einem Boot zu
erreichen, im Winter mit dem Snowmobil.
Die nächste Stadt liegt 60 Kilometer
entfernt.
Oft sind sie hier in der Hardangervidda,
der größten Hochebene Europas,
wochenlang von der Außenwelt
abgeschnitten.
Es ist nicht immer so einfach. Es hört
sich immer alles an, es ist toll
und es ist Romantik.
Selten bekommen sie Besuch. Der
nächste Nachbar ist kilometerweit entfernt.
Das ist’n raues Volk hier
und das ist es auch am Anfang, ne.
Die haben jetzt nicht so die
Willkommensmentalität
wie jetzt so ein Spanier, der dann
sagt: okay, Fiesta
und Siesta und was weiß ich und
wir feiern.
Die gucken erst mal, und sagen:
Wir wollen erst mal abwarten,
ob die den ersten Winter überleben hier.
Ja, und jetzt sind’s neun, und mittlerweile
sind wir angekommen.
Um gleich wieder durchzustarten,
600 Kilometer mit dem Schlitten durch
Russland:
Sie ist die einzige Frau unter den
Teilnehmern und nur sie gelangt ans Ziel.
Eisern kämpft sie sich auch 1.600
Kilometer durch Alaska
– beim internationalen Schlittenrennen
„Yukon-Quest“.
Ist auch beim „Iditarod“-Rennen dabei,
einem der härtesten.
Eine Tortur für Mensch und Tier.
Als ich die Ziellinie überquert habe,
da war mir klar:
Egal, was kommt in meinem Leben
– ich schaff alles.
Das Extreme,
dieses …
das hat ja nicht nur was damit zu tun,
sind die Hunde gut drauf
und bin ich gut drauf.
Das ist das Mentale.
Das ist so dieses Einssein mit der Natur,
mit den Tieren, mit dir selber …
schaffe ich es, allen Widrigkeiten, die
da auf mich zukommen, zu trotzen?
Aufgeben kommt für sie nicht in Frage.
Im Sport wie im Leben.
Ihren Platz hat sie hier gefunden
– irgendwo in der norwegischen Wildnis.
1300 Kilometer von Deutschland entfernt.
Heimat ist für mich da, wo ich mich
wohlfühle
und wo meine Familie sich wohlfühlt,
und das ist hier.
Heimat ist nicht Deutschland,
Ursprung ist Deutschland, aber Heimat
ist jetzt der Platz hier.
Eis und Schnee,
extreme Kälte
und extreme Lebensbedingungen.
Das ist das, was Silvia Furtwängler
glücklich macht.